in other videos we have touched on the
idea of property rights but in this
video we're going to go a little bit
deeper and think about how property
rights connects to the notion of a
market
so first of all think about what a
market means to you you have probably
heard of things like the stock market or
you have probably gone to a supermarket
to do your groceries what's common about
these things
well if we want to say as broad of a
definition of a market you could view it
as a market forms let me write this down
well this is an informal definition
forms
when multiple parties
multiple parties
exchange things of value
exchange
things
of
value and let's see whether our notions
of a market hold up or whether this
definition holds up when we think about
our notions of a market well in a stock
market you have a bunch of people
together and they are trading stocks
and usually what happens is let's see if
this is a stock right over here these
are all different shares of could be the
same stock or of different stocks what
typically happens is if there might be
parties who want to sell this stock and
then there's other parties who want to
buy this stock and then whoever of
whoever of the buyers is willing to
offer
the most for that share well
then that money will go to the seller of
the stock and then that stock will go to
the party that just paid that amount and
so you see that there's an exchange of
things of value
at a supermarket you will see aisles and
aisles of goods this is my drawing of a
isle of goods and there's all sorts of
merchandise on them and you put them in
your shopping cart and then when you're
done you go to
the checkout it's my little shopping
cart here you go to the checkout and you
pay for them so once again you are
picking which items you want there's a
price on them so the seller which in
this case is the supermarket tells you
what they're willing to take for those
items and then when you put them in your
cart and then take it to the checkout
that's you agreeing to pay those prices
and so you exchange once again money for
those things of value so the money has
value and those groceries or whatever
you're buying might have value
now we tend to believe that markets are
the best way of allocating resources and
different markets work different ways as
you could just see the stock market
could be very different than a
supermarket and then you could have an
auction where things are auctioned off
that would also be a form of a market
but the actual mechanics of how things
happen would be a little bit different
but a key factor that you need in order
for markets to function properly is that
you need to have a notion of property
rights and as we've talked about in
previous videos property rights are the
idea that things can be
owned
now what does it mean to own something
we almost just take this for granted but
it's not some law of the universe it's
something that we just assume culturally
and it's become so embedded in us that
we just say of course you can own
something
but at the end of the day there's three
real properties to owning something one
is the idea
of a party being able to exclusively own
something so let's say that you own a
piece of land that you want to farm on
well that means that you can exclude
others from using that land and whatever
that land produces it might just be a
fun place for you to run around or to
sunbathe or it might be a place where
you grow some food that you have the
rights to the benefits of that thing
now another key
dimension of property rights is that
those rights have to be enforceable
enforceable
what does that mean well if someone
obnoxious wants to come and sunbathe on
your property that you have enjoyed
running around and sunbathing on you say
hey you're infringing on my property
rights and you should be able to call
the police or some type of enforcers to
take that person off your land if you
really do have property rights and if
they are truly exclusive or let's say
you have property rights on your shoes
and if someone were to steal your shoes
you should be able to call the police
and say a crime has been committed and
the police should enforce those property
rights they should go and get those
shoes back and punish that shoe stealer
in some way
and then last but not least in order for
markets to work well those property
rights have to be transferable
remember a market is all about
transferring property rights in the
stock market the one party is giving is
transferring their property rights to
that money to the seller of the stock in
exchange for getting the seller of the
stock's property rights to the actual
stocks if this was not transferable then
it would actually make no sense to have
a market as we know it
so i'll leave you there these are things
in our daily life that most of us take
for granted because we live in a market
economy and we are used to things like
ownership but there are definitely ways
of organizing society where it's not as
based on markets in terms of who gets
what and even today markets in many
sectors or in many parts of the world
don't operate as well as they could
because some of these dimensions of
property rights aren't working as
properly as they should it might be hard
to transfer property rights in certain
markets in certain markets if someone
let's say just takes over a property the
government might not be so good at
enforcing those property rights or it
might be hard to keep one party from
using something of value that is at
least according to the property rights
owned by someone else